elephants dog is a valuable resource for
people here
members of the Katara community who live
near the Queen Elizabeth National Park
collects these droppings as a raw
material for paper Moses a gaba is
heading up the project he picked up on
the idea after a group of tourists
explained the process to him after a
long time suffering because of elephants
crossing the boundary and destroy our
crops we look away on how we can get the
composition for the crops which are
destroyed by the elephants the plants
eaten by elephants contain fiber that
makes excellent paper the women first
softened the dung boiling and washing it
to clean it thoroughly
the remaining fibres are then milled
into a poppy mass and dried the katara
community uses the paper to make bags
notebooks and event cards scraps can be
turned into necklaces the community's
products are purchased by lodges in the
park and sold on to tourists for between
five and fifteen dollars we use some of
the money to buy school materials from
orphaned children half of it occurs in
three seven scheme that provides us
balloons while the rest we reinvest in
our hand-press other villagers have also
turned to collect an elephant dung these
farmers build makeshift houses in their
fields to keep watch over the crops when
the elephants come they try to chase
them away but keep the drop-ins on
average they collect about 100 kilograms
of dung
every week when the elephants have
headed back to the park we go out and
get the dog dry it and sell it to the
Katara community I earn 3 dollars for
each bucket and that helps me buy
something
gyuma probe of imprisonment or Toonami
so coolly in Uganda many farmers are
women often they are widows with no
other source of income their husbands
were killed while poaching in the park
the elephant's pose a real threat to
their crops but being able to make an
income from their dung has helped change
the attitude towards the elephants we no
longer have bad feelings about it now
we're focusing on improving this project
its openness to pay for our children's
school fees they would grow up to be
other Parker's in fact pleased because
their fathers were killed there they
also start projects like this wildlife
authorities say the katara communities
helping Uganda's population of five
thousand elephants to grow back in the
1980s they were just 700 of the animals
left in the country moses' gaba and
others in the project are committed to
the cause at first our people around
there is very keen elephants to get
ivory for sale and others the key they
kill to get meat for sale and others
they poison because of being annoying
so we also trying to reduce the
extinction of elephants in our community
because as I talk people now they are no
longer killing elephants they're no
longer poisoning elephants because they
are gaining they're getting income out
of conserving that elephants and with
the elephant population growing business
is booming and Moses Agabus papermaking
startup